back here in southern nevada more people  are enjoying  lake mead the national park service says  8 million people  visited the recreation area in 2020  that's up half a million visitors from  2019  lake mead is now the fifth most visited  site in the entire  national park service we've talked about  a lot sherry people wanted to get  outside in the during the pandemic just  to get in some fresh air and some open  space and  lake mead's one way to do it yes yes it  is and it's great out there it draws a  lot of people out but let me just  say please if you are going to head out  maybe even this weekend  with the nice sunshine we've got more  wind coming so please  life jackets make sure you're protected  if you're going to be out there on the  water we've got